[Music]
on this Wednesday night two Ontario
police officers gunned down in the line
of duty this is a heartbreaking time for
our food service the victims the suspect
and the deadly confrontation
when Alberta's Premier claims about the
unvaccinated they have been the most
discriminated against group that I've
ever witnessed the facts and the
reaction
endometriosis patients plea for help it
is such a challenging disease to
understand the costly delays in
diagnosing the painful chronic condition
and the race between flying car
companies
competition soars to take our commute to
the sky
full National with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a devastating crime
in a small Ontario Town two police
officers were shot and killed while
responding to a call at a home in
Innisfil Ontario it's a town on the
shore of Lake Simcoe about an hour and a
half north of Toronto
Constable's Morgan Russell and Devin
Northrup were rushed to hospital last
night but did not survive a 23-year-old
suspect Who police say exchanged gunfire
with those officers died at the scene
Mike drolet is near the crime scene in
Innisfil Mike
Donna it was described as pandemonium on
this quiet street some residents say the
idea of a shootout seems so far-fetched
they thought all the commotion was for
someone having a heart attack but two
cops killed no they said certainly not
here
the air ambulance carry in Constable
Morgan Russell landed at the trauma
center in Toronto just before midnight
he died early Wednesday morning a
heartbreaking end to a deadly
confrontation in the previously quiet
town of Innisfil just north of Toronto
words cannot describe our grief police
say they received a complaint for a
disturbance although they won't say what
it was once inside the home Russell and
his partner Devin Northrup went to the
basement there was an exchange of
gunfire between two officers and the man
and that man was pronounced deceased at
the scene Global News has identified the
suspect as 23-year-old Chris Doncaster
neighbors say he had been staying in the
basement of the home owned by his
grandparents who were upstairs shares
when the gunfire began unsettling and
disheartening to have a cop shot right
on your street you know
but that's what this world is coming to
just more and more violence violence
begets violence
it's been a particularly heartbreaking
month for law enforcement in Ontario
with Russell and Northrop becoming the
third and fourth officers killed in the
line of duty I know the families of
people who serve
are always worried for their loved ones
please know that we stand with you as
families
it's uh unsure of where to go friends
and colleagues of the two officers
gathered at the Town Hall where they
spoke of their impact on the community
the 33 year old Northrop was relatively
new to the force but was a key part of
the mental health unit and Morgan one of
the most senior members on the force was
called one of the better ones this is
personal for me
I went to police college with Morgan 33
years ago
Morgan could have retired three years
ago but stayed on I know that Morgan was
going to retire once his daughters were
finished University
yeah
we're almost there the SIU are now
involved so police are extremely Limited
in what they can say but people here
including the former colleagues of the
two officers killed are desperate to
understand what happened in that
basement Donna Mike relay in innisville
Ontario thanks now to Alberta where the
new premier is attempting to clarify
something she said yesterday that
generated a great deal of reaction here
is what Danielle Smith said after her
swearing-in
the community that faced the most
restrictions on their freedoms in the
last year were those who made a choice
not to be vaccinated so they have been
the most discriminated against group
that I've ever witnessed in my lifetime
that's a pretty extreme level of
discrimination that we have seen I don't
take away any of the Discrimination that
I've seen in those other groups that you
mentioned but this has been an
extraordinary time in the last year in
particular Smith also pledged to protect
unvaccinated people under the Alberta
Human Rights Act her claim that they are
the group most discriminated against was
not backed up with evidence and it drew
widespread criticism from indigenous
Jewish and Muslim groups among others
BC's Premier called it laughable today
Smith put out a statement saying she did
not intend to trivialize in any way the
Discrimination faced by minority
communities and other persecuted groups
Global's Brianna Karsten Smith is in
Edmonton Brianna she's not saying story
or that she made a mistake what's been
the real action
dawn of the premier's latest words are
simply not enough according to multiple
groups we've heard from instead they're
now calling on her to actually take
action as you mentioned the premier
British Columbia has weighed in while
speaking on a radio show in Victoria
calling Smith's comments laughable John
Horgan says he disagrees with the
comments made by Alberta's new premier
saying she's focusing on a sliver of the
population when there are other
challenges going on the Jewish
Federation of Edmonton released a
statement saying we have reached out to
the premier's office to express our
concerns and are keen on meeting with
Smith to discuss anti-Semitism
discrimination and the need for
mandatory Holocaust Education also a
McEwen University professor and leading
researcher on gender and youth points
out people within the 2s lgbtq plus
Community continue to face
discrimination including as recently as
last month here in Edmonton when a group
was targeted with threats of violence
for Gathering
when you hear those kind of comments
from our new premier people are
wondering
um am I really safe with this in this
province am I really valued am I
welcoming in this province and I think
that's exactly the kind of wrong kind of
message that we want to send
Smith did say Smith did say in her
statement that she's committed to
listening learning and addressing the
issues affecting minority communities
adding over the next few days my office
will be reaching out to set up meetings
with minority Community stakeholders so
I can better understand the different
concerns of their individual communities
Donna all right Brianna Carson Smith in
Edmonton thanks in the U.S conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones has been ordered to
pay a colossal amount in Damages for the
lies he spread about the shooting
massacre at Sandy Hook Elementary School
in 2012. a Connecticut Jury has ordered
Jones to pay nearly one billion dollars
to the families of eight of the victims
of that school shooting and an FBI agent
who responded 20 children and six
teachers were killed in the shooting
last year a judge ruled Jones and the
parent company of Infowars are liable
for defamation because Jones spent years
calling the shooting a hoax and
described the dead children and their
grieving parents as crisis actors in a
previous trial Jones was over to pay
nearly 50 million dollars to another
family a third trial is still pending
in Ottawa the decision to invoke the
federal emergencies act back in February
is under scrutiny hundreds of vehicles
and people occupied the streets adjacent
to Parliament Hill for weeks and refused
to leave the Prime Minister maintains
invoking the Act was necessary and right
others including the Canadian civil
liberties Association believe it was
unlawful and unconstitutional all of
those involved will have a chance to
make their case at a public inquiry
which starts tomorrow it must by law
happen whenever the emergencies Act is
invoked to ensure accountability and
oversight Eric Sorensen explains who
will testify and what's at stake
Wellington Street the main road to view
Parliament Hill has never returned to
normal off limits to cars and truck
traffic the most visible and lasting
impact of this
the Convoy of protesters who blockaded
streets last winter upset over such
things as vaccine mandates they shut
down Commerce and ordinary life in the
city center for weeks authorities
largely stood watch until Ottawa invoked
the emergencies act that granted among
other things extraordinary powers to
police to clear people out of the
downtown
but was the emergencies act appropriate
a measure so serious that it triggers a
public inquiry which begins tomorrow
Ontario appeal court justice Paul Rulo
is the inquiry's commissioner among
those with standing as participants the
federal Alberta and Saskatchewan
governments the cities of Ottawa and
Windsor the Ottawa Police Service and a
group of prominent Convoy organizers
including Tamara Leach and Chris Barber
who also faced charges that include
obstructing police
among dozens of expected Witnesses the
Prime Minister says he will be available
to testify we move forward
with measures that are not to be taken
lightly but that we brought forward with
emergencies act in a Time limited
measured way to be able to get the
situation back under control but the
Canadian civil liberties Association
questions the powers used to freeze
assets of protesters and says Ottawa
went too far using the emergencies act
not as a truly Last Resort it is our
opinion that their actions were unlawful
and unconstitutional the government has
yet to prove that the legal threshold to
invoke the Act was met for local shops
that depend on visitors the harm is
still being felt Wellington Street has
stayed closed it's been devastating for
us to have these streets closed there's
concern that the impact on the local
community will get short shrift in a
politically charged National inquiry
that inquiry begins Thursday in ottawa's
library and archives building very near
where the protests occurred the hearings
will last about six weeks with the
inquiries report due next February Eric
Sorensen Global News
Jewish groups are calling for more
action against online hate because of
the case of an immigration consultant
hired by the federal government lathema
roof whose Twitter accounts have been
suspended sent a series of vile
anti-semitic tweets while he was
receiving Federal funding for
anti-racism programs it took more than a
month for the diversity minister to
react and suspend that funding Abigail
Beeman reports
life is too short for shoes with laces
or for entertaining Jewish white
supremacists with anything but a bullet
to the head that's just one of many
anti-semitic tweets from laith maroof
whose organization received Federal
funding for anti-racism programs until
an outcry prompted the government to cut
it in August opinions expressed by this
individual were reprehensible and
unacceptable and the fact that this
individual was able to secure Government
funding through the organization was
absolutely wrong the diversity Minister
admitted he first learned about the
issue more than a month before cutting
funds I was on on July then the 19th or
20th I just want to know why it took so
long did no one Google Mr marouf his
wife the organization you have to be
somewhat concerned about a 30 or 35 day
time lag but the center for Israel and
Jewish Affairs and other Jewish advocacy
groups are not slamming the minister
acknowledging things take time and
pleased the government has committed to
better vetting going forward several
groups are calling for the crtc to cut
payments that marouf's organization
receives to participate in matters heard
by the commission what applies to
government essentially using taxpayer
funds should extend to all Crown
corporations all this against a backdrop
of rising anti-Semitism our 2021 audit
is the highest number of anti-Semitic
hate crimes and hate incidents that have
ever been recorded by benebraith there's
a push for Swifter action from the
government for its proposed online
anti-hate legislation while at least two
of maruth's Twitter accounts were
suspended we need you to take down those
zionists who appointed themselves as
your leaders he finds other platforms
defending himself and doubling down in
this YouTube video prime minister
Trudeau's false accusations against me
fall under hate propaganda in a criminal
code of Canada
it is a charge worth two years of jail
time we asked
that I've interview about why it took
more than a month to cut funding his
office didn't even respond to our
request Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
more aid for Ukraine coming out what
Canada and other NATO allies are sending
to help in the fight against Russia
this is the impact of Russian missiles
on civilians in Ukraine a family trapped
in the rubble of their building in
zapparesia they managed to crawl to
safety one by one
the southern city is one of many hit by
a barrage of Russian missiles over the
past few days there are fears more
people may be buried in that Rubble
the Russian president says the air
strikes a retaliation for the attack on
its vital bridge to Crimea on Saturday
and Vladimir Putin blames Ukraine's
Military Intelligence service today
Russia detained eight people its
suspects carried out that blast five
Russian citizens two from Ukraine and
one Armenian Ukraine's allies are
reaffirming their support to strengthen
its defenses more than 50 Western
countries met at NATO headquarters today
promising to supply more weapons as
Crystal gemancing Reports Canada will be
providing another 47 million dollars in
military aid
in Aid of Ukraine Canada's defense
minister came to the table alongside
NATO allies armed with a new support
package two million dollars with a
satellite Communications 15 million in
drone cameras 15 million in military
equipment plus more ammunition we know
that Ukraine has been needing and asking
for additional artillery in particular
the 155 millimeter artillery that is a
long-range round used in Howitzer M
triple sevens like this one global news
on action in eastern Ukraine
front line resupplies are desperately
needed as Ukraine continues its
offensive to reclaim territory from
invading Russian forces
Authority right now however is aerial
protection
Ukraine's prime minister says over the
past three days it has seen 128 strikes
at least 27 energy infrastructure sites
have been attacked a power plant in
nipro Petrovic oblast which supplies
Europe's largest nuclear plant was
knocked offline again Wednesday
ahead of the international atomic energy
agency has been meeting with Ukraine's
president and Russia's in hopes of
creating a protection Zone around the
site the Secretary General of NATO
reaffirmed its unwavering support for
Ukraine the attacks on the energy
infrastructure is serious as we approach
winter so all of this demonstrates the
urgent need for more air defense for
Ukraine the broader Coalition known as
the Ukrainian defense contact group used
the NATO Gathering to talk next steps
we'll do as much as it takes for as long
as it takes
with fears over Russia's veiled nuclear
threats
and recent strikes near Europe's largest
nuclear plant day two of the NATO
Gathering will focus on nuclear safety
Crystal commencing Global News London
a leak has been found in the largest
pipeline that carries Russian oil to
Central Europe there is no clear
evidence of sabotage the leak is
believed to be the result of an accident
Europe is already facing a severe energy
crisis because of the Russian invasion
of Ukraine and the shutdown and
subsequent sabotage of the Nordstrom
natural gas pipeline
ahead desperate pleas for National
Action and on agonizing medical
condition for women
[Music]
endometriosis is a painful and complex
disease that affects one in ten girls
and women and an unknown number of
transgender and gender diverse people
many spend years struggling to get a
proper diagnosis dismissed by doctors
and failing to get access to appropriate
care as Jamie Maraca explains Advocates
say it's time that changed
Colby Morley says for almost two decades
she was ignored by doctors honestly it
goes back to being like 14 and having a
lot of pain and going to the emergency
room and no one ever knowing what's
wrong with me and being told it's in my
head it's stress it wasn't until last
year the now 33 year old was diagnosed
with endometriosis a condition where
tissue similar to that found in the
uterine lining grows outside of it
causing extreme pelvic pain soreness
during sex heavy menstrual bleeding
cramping and even infertility there are
common symptoms but it affects everybody
so individually that it really is that
is I think part of the part of why it is
such a challenging disease to understand
and and to help treat in Canada
diagnosis delays have become an
unfortunate Norm ranging from 5 to 20
years a cost that rings in at almost 2
billion dollars annually in doctors
appointments hospital visits
transportation and even miss just work
or school it's a very multi-baceted
problem so that it starts with first of
all not being able to even discuss
women's health issues uh issues around
period pain
um and the difficulties around
understanding chronic pelvic pain in
general
in 2020 the U.S doubled annual federal
research funding for endometriosis and
two years before that the Australian
government published its plan to
increase awareness education and
management of the chronic disease but
when asked Health Minister Johnny duclow
wouldn't commit to immediate action here
we would certainly want to continue
listening to the to the patient groups
the researchers to see how we can
strengthen even more both our
investments and the outcomes for for
patients a private member's motion
calling for Approved access to care and
education was proposed in March it
hasn't yielded results Morley had
laparoscopic surgery in February to
confirm her diagnosis still suffering
she says she won't be waiting on Ottawa
I'll do anything to get my quality of
life back willing to seek treatment
outside Canada paying further relief she
should be able to access at home for
free Jamie moroccer Global News Toronto
ride to the Future next flying into the
new reality
flying cars long ago stopped being the
stuff of Science Fiction a race is
underway to develop them and make them
commercially viable hundreds of millions
of dollars are being spent in many
prototypes of aerial vehicles are being
tested getting closer to becoming an
everyday reality as Ross Lord reports
one flying car made its public debut
this week above the streets of Dubai
this is a new entry in an old contest
mastering the production of flying cars
that will be the very important base for
the Next Generation flying car the
Chinese company xpeng says its X2 model
can travel up to 130 kilometers an hour
emitting zero carbon dioxide and could
perform as a personal vehicle or for air
patrols and emergency rescues xping says
the X2 has a foldable rotor mechanism
for going back and forth between driving
and flying reaching New Heights and a
long-standing cultural Obsession didn't
you ever space ski to school when you
were a kid Mom
[Music]
some previous prototypes might be
considered laughable today like this one
from the 1940s that simply welded a
small car to the bottom of a plane
flying cars are now at the center of a
global spending spree that includes the
major automakers and individual
developers like Canada's Marcus Lang
here she goes
he's taken his idea from Ontario to
California's Silicon Valley I think
we've all had dreams of complete
three-dimensional Freedom xping says
mass production of the X2 will start by
2024. the flying car is selling for
about 150 000 US dollars a piece
technology that was predicted a long
time ago could finally be coming true
Ross Lord Global News
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight
Sierra Canada is
Ontario we
always and thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]